[Música]
hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América me acompaña en el
estudio Juan Pablo lucumí en su Debut en
la sección económica Muchas gracias Juan
Pablo por acompañarnos hoy comenzamos
hablando precisamente de lo que
significa la reapertura de ese paso
fronterizo o de los pasos fronterizos
entre Colombia y Venezuela Buenas noches
así es Santiago buenas noches y muchas
gracias Pues si nos remontamos unos años
en 2016 el intercambio comercial entre
Colombia y Venezuela sumaba casi dos mil
millones de dólares una cifra que se
disparó en 2008 a los 5.000 millones de
dólares pero tras siete años de flujo
comercial interrumpido ahora no ha
logrado superar los 400 millones ahora
si hablamos de la meta que se ha
propuesto a ambos países Es que la cifra
llegue a mil millones de dólares
compradores de alimentos y productos de
belleza así como proveedores de
materiales de construcción y cientos de
pequeños negocios son los que están
directamente beneficiados sobre todo en
el lado venezolano Pues ahora incluso
ese país la posibilidad de exportar
también se espera que con esta decisión
se transmite el tránsito ilegal se
termine perdón el tránsito ilegal que ha
provocado la expansión de bandas
criminales y actos delictivos en la
frontera el acto de reapertura en el
cual estuvo el presidente colombiano
pero no estuvo su homólogo venezolano
fue calificado por ambos mandatarios
como un hecho histórico escuchemos
creo que hoy es un día histórico
para la región para el país para América
del Sur
para América en general
la globalización
es Antes que nada una relación entre
vecinos la reapertura de la frontera
entre Colombia y Venezuela es
indudablemente un hecho histórico que
marca el comienzo de una etapa de
relaciones de hermandad respeto y paz
somos pueblos Unidos por el lazo
inquebrantable del bolivarianismo Juan
Pablo después de muchos días de
especulación fue aprobado el despido del
jefe del banco interamericano de
desarrollo qué fue lo que pasó allí
cuéntenos pues este lunes en un
comunicado del banco interamericano de
desarrollo bit confirmó el cese oficial
de su presidente Mauricio claver carone
luego de una votación unánime que habría
comenzado Hace unos días atrás la razón
las acusaciones contra claver de haber
mantenido una relación romántica con una
subordinada Desde 2019 cuando ambos
trabajaban en la casa blanca y que pues
esta relación continuó otras
investigaciones también lo señalan de
haber violado las reglas de ética Al
haber aumentado el sueldo a su jefa de
gabinete clave ha negado la relación y
señaló que las acusaciones representaban
fallas graves el cubano estadounidense
de 62 años fue nominado para un mandato
de cinco años por el entonces presidente
Donald Trump y asumió el cargo En
octubre de 2020 ahora será la
vicepresidenta ejecutiva La Hondureña
reina Mejía Quien será la sustituta del
banco de forma interina Juan Pablo
hablemos ahora del Reino Unido porque la
moneda local la libra esterlina se cayó
a mínimos históricos frente al Dólar que
cada vez está más fuerte
internacionalmente así es Santiago pues
este lunes después de muchas operaciones
la libra esterlina cayó a mínimos
históricos frente al dólar
estadounidense esto después de que el
ministro de economía británico
prometiera un amplio paquete de recortes
de impuestos que él espera sirvan para
el crecimiento del país en medio de una
elevada inflación la decisión anunciada
el viernes alimentó las preocupaciones
sobre la política económica del gobierno
e incrementa la especulación en una de
una profunda recesión la caída fue casi
del 5% llegando a los 1,03 dólares y
extendió la ya preocupante él ya
preocupante descenso cuando el viernes
pasado llegó a 3,6%. el mínimo histórico
anterior de la libra esterlina frente al
Dólar fue hace 37 años en
1985 hablemos ahora de la cifra del día
para el cierre así es Santiago pues se
espera que el 5% de la producción del
último celular de Apple no sé si usted
ya lo tiene hablamos del iPhone 14 que
se lanzó a inicios de este mes se
empiece a fabricar en India a finales de
este año se prevé que este 5% aumente a
un 25% de la fabricación por fuera de
China para 2025 una decisión que
seguramente y como han dicho analistas
ha dado se ha dado por el riesgo de las
cadenas de suministro y los estrictos
cierres por las políticas Cero covid en
el país hacia atrás veremos la respuesta
china entonces Muchas gracias Juan Pablo
por esta información ustedes Pueden
seguir con nosotros ya viene el debate
[Música]